you all know there is a global push
towards greater transparency and clarity
of our tax regimes I am pleased to
announce that we have agreed today major
milestones along in all this to happen
namely the criteria and the process for
the establishment of an EU list of non
cooperative jurisdictions in taxation
matters we had a hour after partners
here today for the annual exchange of
views to this cassock elicitation filled
with focus on economic growth investment
there is a common understanding that we
need to strengthen the economic growth
in employment the CCTV we will
contribute to fighting again aggressive
tax planning and cross-border tax abuse
it will eliminate the mismatches and
loop calls between national systems
which companies can currently exploit
today ministers had a first discussion
on our proposal and the first round of
feedback is broadly encouraging I would
also like to thank the slower presidency
for its efforts to achieve progress in
the anti-money laundering director from
today's discussions two points deserve
some clarification first there seems to
be a certain debate regarding prepaid
cards it is important to stress that the
Commission does not propose to ban these
cards what P proposed is to ensure a
better traceability of who is using
these cards and second on transparency
requirements for beneficial owners we
wish to reiterate the importance of
enhancing access to information on who
is a real beneficial owner behind a
company or atras final point we have a
good news related to the banking Union
on the banking recovery and resolution
directive Belgium was the last member
state to transpose it and we expect to
receive a notification in the coming
days